Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. Or, if you're listening on the Apple Podcasts app, you can subscribe within the app in just a few clicks. At daylight, saw the enemy's combined fleet from east to east-southeast, bore away, made the signal for order of sailing and to prepare for battle,
感谢您收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。若想收听每周独家加更节目、无广告广播、提前解锁系列内容并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。感谢您收听《历史的余烬》。若想收听加更节目、提前解锁内容、享受无广告广播并加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。或者，如果您使用的是 Apple Podcasts App，只需点击几下即可在 App 内订阅。天亮时，从东到东南偏东方向发现了敌人的联合舰队，（我方）转舵，打出编队航行和准备战斗的信号，
the enemy with their heads to the southward. At seven, the enemy wearing in succession. May the great God whom I worship grant to my country and for the benefit of Europe in general a great and glorious victory, and may no misconduct in anyone tarnish it, and may humanity after victory be the predominant feature in the British fleet. For myself individually, I commit my life to him who made me and may his blessing light upon my endeavors for serving my country faithfully. To him I resign myself and the just cause which is entrusted to me to defend. Amen. Amen. Amen.
敌人船头朝南。七点钟，敌人相继掉头。愿我所崇拜的伟大上帝，赐予我的国家以及整个欧洲的福祉一场伟大而光荣的胜利，愿没有任何人的失职玷污它，也愿胜利后的人道主义成为英国舰队最显著的特征。至于我个人，我将生命托付给创造我的人，愿他的祝福照亮我忠诚报效祖国的努力。我将自己以及托付给我捍卫的正义事业交付于他。阿门。阿门。阿门。
So, Tom, that was the last diary entry by Horatio Nelson on the morning of Monday, the 21st of October, 1805. Very stirring words, I have to say. the development of the Royal Navy, the financial and political underpinnings, extraordinary maneuverings to and fro across the Atlantic as Nelson chases Villeneuve, his French antagonist. And now here we are, the moment of decision. The dawn is coming and I know you're poised to take us through blow blow by blow, the narrative? Yes. So it's just before dawn on the 21st of October, 1805, about quarter to six in the morning. And the lookouts on the masts of the British fleet spy the enemy. They're about 12 miles downwind from the British fleet. And it's confirmation that the French and Spanish have not withdrawn, have not retreated, and therefore there is an opportunity for battle. So the British are about 22 miles off Cape
所以，汤姆，那是霍雷肖·纳尔逊在1805年10月21日星期一早上的最后日记。我必须说，这些话非常激动人心。皇家海军的发展、财政和政治支柱，纳尔逊追击其法国对手维尔纳夫时在大西洋两岸的非凡机动。现在我们来到了这里，决定性的时刻。黎明即将到来，我知道你正准备为我们逐一剖析这场叙事？是的。就在1805年10月21日黎明前夕，大约早晨五点四十五分。英国舰队桅杆上的瞭望员发现了敌人。他们位于英国舰队下风向大约12英里处。这证实了法国人和西班牙人没有撤退，因此存在着交战的机会。所以英国人距离角
Trafalgar, which lies between Cadiz and Gibraltar. Taraf al-Ghar, so Arabic, the point of the cave. It's a clear day. The previous day had been wet, had been cloudy, very poor visibility. But on the 21st of October, it's about 21 degrees. So pretty unseasonably warm, but just the faint hint of a swell. So possibility of a storm coming later in due course. But the day itself, 21st of October, looks a good day to be fighting a sea battle. The British have 26 ships. The French and Spanish between them have 33 ships. The French and Spanish ships have been kind of mixed up so that there's no prospect of either one national squadron sailing off and abandoning the other.
特拉法加（Trafalgar）大约22英里，该角位于加的斯和直布罗陀之间。Taraf al-Ghar，源自阿拉伯语，意为“山洞之角”。这是一个晴朗的日子。前一天曾下过雨，多云，能见度非常低。但在10月21日，气温约为21度。可以说是反常的温暖，但带有轻微的涌浪。因此预示着稍后可能会有风暴来袭。但这一天本身，即10月21日，看起来是进行海战的好日子。英国拥有26艘战舰。法西联合舰队则拥有33艘战舰。法兰西和西班牙的战舰被混合编组，这样一来，任何一个国家的舰队单独航行并抛弃另一方的可能性都不复存在。
The French flagship is the Boussaintour, named after the gilded barge of the Doge in Venice. That is where Villeneuve is. It's not in absolutely tip top shape because it had just recently been struck by lightning, which is further added to Villeneuve's kind of slight mood of despondency. And Villeneuve is in the centre of the line as it's sailing down towards Gibraltar. He has with him a Spanish rear admiral, Balthazar de Cisneros, and he is in command of the Santissima Trinidad, so the most sacred trinity. The biggest ship in the world. And it's the biggest ship in the world.
法国的旗舰是“布桑托尔号”（Boussaintour），以威尼斯总督的镀金驳船命名。维尔纳夫就在那里。它的状态并不是绝对的巅峰，因为它最近刚遭到雷击，这进一步加剧了维尔纳夫那种有些沮丧的情绪。维尔纳夫位于正南下直布罗陀的战列线中央。与他同行的还有西班牙海军少将巴尔塔萨·德·西斯内罗斯（Balthazar de Cisneros），他指挥的是“圣特立尼达号”（Santissima Trinidad），即最神圣三位一体号。世界上面积最大的战舰。这也是世界上面积最大的战舰。
It's the only one with four decks of guns. Yeah. So an absolute trophy. The British are absolutely itching to get their hands on it. The vanguard is commanded by another Spanish admiral, Ignacio de Alva, and he's on a ship called the Santa Ana. And the rear guard is commanded by a Frenchman, Pierre Dumenoir, and he is on board a ship called the Formidable. The Spanish admiral, so the overall commander, Frederico Gravina, he is on a ship called the Principe de Asturias, and he is commanding what Villeneuve calls
它是唯一一艘拥有四层火炮甲板的战舰。是的。绝对是一件战利品。英国人对此垂涎三尺，急于将其据为已有。前卫舰队由另一位西班牙海军上将伊格纳西奥·德·阿尔瓦（Ignacio de Alva）指挥，他的座舰名为“圣安娜号”（Santa Ana）。后卫舰队由法国人皮埃尔·迪马努瓦尔（Pierre Dumenoir）指挥，他的座舰是“可畏号”（Formidable）。西班牙海军上将、也就是总指挥官费德里科·格拉维纳（Frederico Gravina），他的座舰名为“阿斯图里亚斯亲王号”（Principe de Asturias），他指挥的是维尔纳夫所称的
the Squadron of Observation, which is basically a kind of reserve. So this is the plan that Villeneuve suspects what Nelson is going to do. And so he doesn't know where Nelson will be targeting his attack. And so his plan is that he's going to have this tactical reserve to kind of come up
“观察舰队”，基本上是一种预备队。这就是维尔纳夫对纳尔逊意图的猜测。因此，他并不知道纳尔逊会将攻击目标锁定在何处。他的计划是保留这支战术预备队，以便在
wherever it's needed. So that's the plan. Meanwhile, of course, Nelson has his plans. He has told all the captains of the fleet exactly what he's going to do. Namely, he's going to form two prongs. One of them is going to be led by himself on victory. The other one is going to be led by Admiral Collingwood, Nelson's old friend, the man that he most respects and admires among his colleagues. And he is going to be on a ship called the Royal Sovereign. So essentially, Nelson and Collingwood are the tip
任何需要的地方随时增援。这就是计划。与此同时，纳尔逊当然也有他的计划。他已经将自己确切的作战意图告知了舰队的所有舰长。也就是说，他将组成两支突击纵队。其中一支将由他亲自率领的“胜利号”（Victory）带头。另一支将由纳尔逊的老朋友、他在同僚中最尊重和钦佩的人——海军中将科林伍德（Collingwood）率领。他的座舰是一艘名为“皇家主权号”（Royal Sovereign）的战舰。因此，本质上，纳尔逊和科林伍德就是
of the spear. They are in the position of maximum danger. And there's some nervousness about this on the part of Collingwood and many of his colleagues. And they've tried to persuade Nelson that perhaps victory should hang back or that he should get on another ship and nelson of course absolutely scorns that because it's yeah you know the whole mystique of nelson's charisma is that he shares the dangers of his men and in fact as an officer he is obliged to run more risks than his men because he is standing on the court deck which is right you know and as all officers do, they have to stand there. They can't cower. They can't duck.
矛尖。他们处于最危险的位置。科林伍德和他的许多同僚对此感到有些紧张。他们曾试图说服纳尔逊，或许“胜利号”应该留在后面，或者他应该换乘另一艘战舰，而纳尔逊当然对此嗤之以鼻，因为……你知道的，纳尔逊个人魅力的全部神秘之处就在于他与部下共担风险。事实上，作为一名军官，他被迫承担比普通士兵更多的风险，因为他站在后甲板上，那正是……你知道的，正如所有军官所做的那样，他们必须站在那里。他们不能畏缩。他们不能躲避。
It requires absolutely phenomenal qualities of courage. And Nelson, just to be, I mean, by the time he does get on deck, we can maybe just leap ahead for a second. You're talking about the courage. He is wearing his dark blue coat. I mean, you can see what Nelson wore in the National Maritime Museum. Yeah, it's still there. They've still got it haven't they but he's wearing his dark blue coat and he's got gilt buttons 36 gilt buttons and gold epaulets
这需要绝对惊人的勇气品质。而且纳尔逊，仅仅为了……我是说，等他真正登上甲板时，我们也许可以稍微快进一下。你刚才谈到了勇气。他穿着深蓝色的呢子大衣。我是说，你可以在国家海事博物馆看到纳尔逊穿过的衣服。是的，它还在那儿。他们还留着它，不是吗？他穿着深蓝色的呢子大衣，上面有镀金纽扣，36枚镀金纽扣，还有金色的肩章，
and stars adorned on the epaulets so he is absolutely visible you know if you're a frenchman or a spaniard you will see nelson literally glinting because of the stars and whatnot, surrounded by men who are clearly not officers or the mass of the men on the ship. So Nelson is a target. I mean, that's really important. He is a very, very visible target. Absolutely. And one of the things that makes what he's doing incredibly dangerous is that if you imagine two ships parallel to each other firing guns at each other the ribs of the ship serve as a kind of armor but if you imagine them shooting at the at the stern or the rear that's vulnerable and you know if you fire cannonballs say
肩章上装饰着星星，所以他绝对是一目了然的。你知道的，如果你是一个法国人或西班牙人，你会看到纳尔逊因为那些星星和其他装饰而在闪闪发光，周围簇拥着那些明显不是军官的人，或者说是船上的普通士兵。所以纳尔逊是一个活靶子。我的意思是，这非常重要。他是一个非常非常显眼的活靶子。完全正确。使他的行动极度危险的原因之一是：如果你想象两艘船平行航行并互相开火，船肋可以起到某种装甲的作用；但如果你想象敌方攻击船尾或后部，那是极其脆弱的。你知道，如果你发射炮弹，比方说
through the prow it can go straight through the ship. It's called raking. So as Nelson on Victory and Collingwood on the Royal Sovereign approach the French and Spanish line, they will be raked and they will not have an opportunity to fire back because their cannon will obviously not be pointing at the enemy line. So it requires unbelievable reserves of courage to do that but that is what that's nelson's plan uh and at 6 10 in the morning he signals to the fleet form order of sailing in two columns say victory at the head yeah royal sovereign at the head of the second column yeah
穿过船首，它能直接贯穿整艘船。这被称为“纵射”。因此，当纳尔逊乘坐“胜利号”和科林伍德乘坐“皇家主权号”接近法西战列线时，他们将遭到纵射，并且没有机会进行反击，因为他们的加农炮显然无法对准敌人的战列线。因此，这样做需要难以置信的巨大勇气，但这就是纳尔逊的计划。在早上6点10分，他向舰队发出信号：“以两纵队编队航行”，“胜利号”领头，是的，“皇家主权号”率领第二纵队，是的。
6 22 another signal prepare for battle And so they start to move forward. 640, a French figure signals to the Boussaintour, to Villeneuve, on the French flagship, the enemy is in sight to Wynwood. And as the British fleet slowly crosses over the horizon, Villeneuve is absolutely appalled to realise how many British ships there are. There are far more than he had calculated. But he knows that if he retreats now, he's doomed. French honour will be lost.
6点22分，另一个信号：准备战斗。于是他们开始向前推进。6点40分，一艘法国巡防舰向法国旗舰上的维尔纳夫所在的“布桑托尔号”发信号：敌人在下风向出现。随着英国舰队缓缓越过地平线，维尔纳夫惊骇地发现英国战舰的数量竟然如此之多。这远超他的计算。但他知道，如果此时撤退，他就死定了。法兰西的荣誉将荡然无存。
So he is determined to stand and fight. And so he gives orders for his fleet to reverse direction, to turn northwards, to face the British, but they're unpracticed. And this maneuver generates the first Franco-Spanish mistake, which is that the tactical reserve under the command of Gravina, the Spanish admiral, gets jumbled up with all the other ships. And so it loses its coherence and gaps in the line start opening up. Well, if you ever look at a plan of the battle, Tom, the French and Spanish, the combined fleet is meant to be a sort of a line, but it's actually quite raggedy and it's more of a kind of crescent, isn't it? What this means is that Gravina's reverse force, rather than kind of entering as a solid unit, is just kind of entering pell-mell.
因此他决心坚守阵地并迎战。于是他下令舰队掉头向北，迎击英国人，但他们缺乏演练。这一机动引发了法西联合舰队的第一个失误，即在西班牙海军上将格拉维纳指挥下的战术预备队与所有其他战舰混成了一团。因此它失去了连贯性，战列线开始出现缺口。好吧，如果你看过战役部署图，汤姆，法兰西和西班牙的联合舰队本应排成一条直线，但实际上它相当参差不齐，更像是一道新月形，不是吗？这意味着格拉维纳的反击力量并非以一个坚固的整体切入，而是像乱蜂入巢般盲目闯入。
And in the long run, it would be like entering a meat grinder or something. So things are not looking good for the Spanish fleet and the French fleet right from the beginning. The thing that makes the whole onset of the battle kind of unbelievable is that there's enough wind for the British to advance, but not enough for it to be anything more than a kind of walking pace. The British fleet is advancing kind of two, three miles an hour. Yeah. So if it's a film,
从长远来看，这就好比走进绞肉机一样。因此，从一开始，西班牙舰队和法国舰队的情况就不容乐观。整场战役爆发时最令人难以置信的是，风力虽然足以让英国人前进，但却不足以让他们以超过步行速度的速度行进。英国舰队正以每小时两到三英里的速度前进。是的。所以如果是拍电影，
if it's the, if you're making the film with the battle of Trafalgar, I mean, the thing is that they see each other, they start to, you know, everyone is nervous. Everybody's getting ready,
如果是……如果你在拍摄关于特拉法加海战的电影，事情的经过是这样的：他们看到了彼此，他们开始……你知道的，所有人都很紧张。所有人都严阵以待，
but hours will pass. Hours, yes. With them getting closer and closer. It's about six hours, I think, with them moving very, very slowly together. And the tension on board, I mean, the descriptions in the various books. So for example, I mentioned earlier, what I think is one of the most extraordinary history books that I've probably ever reviewed, which is John Sugden's, the second volume of his life of Nelson, which is just so incredibly detailed. And I know you read a book on, is it by Tim Clayton, somebody like that? Yeah, Tim Clayton and Phil Craig, but a really
但数小时将会过去。是的，数小时。他们之间的距离越来越近。我想大约有六个小时，他们以非常非常缓慢的速度向彼此靠近。船上的紧张气氛，我的意思是，各种书籍中的描述……例如，我刚才提到过，我认为这是我读过的最卓越的历史著作之一，即约翰·萨格登（John Sugden）撰写的纳尔逊传记第二卷，其细节简直令人难以置信。我知道你读过一本书，是蒂姆·克莱顿（Tim Clayton）写的吗，诸如此类的人？是的，蒂姆·克莱顿和菲尔·克雷格（Phil Craig），那确实是一本对战役的极好记录。这些关于特拉法加海战的惊人记载之所以如此震撼，是因为那种紧张气氛在几小时又几小时中不断积聚、积聚、再积聚。他们清空甲板，然后英国战舰……当你们准备战斗时，你们会搬走所有的家具，你们会把吊床取下来，吊床你知道的，它们可以作为垫衬物来加固甲板两侧。水手们赤裸着上身，他们在头上缠上头带或绷带，这样可以吸汗并保护眼睛。他们做完了这一切，但接下来依然有大量的等待。事实上，在英国战舰上——所以我们开启了整个史诗般的篇章，我读到了《橡树之心》（Heart of Oak），我的意思是，那是他们唱的歌曲之一，军乐队开始演奏，军乐队在演奏，军乐队在演奏，他们唱着《不列颠尼亚统治吧》（Rule Britannia），他们高唱着上帝国王。
good account of the battle. These amazing accounts of the Battle of Trafalgar. And what makes them so powerful is that sense of the tension building and building and building hour after hour so they they clear the decks and then the british ships what you do is when you're getting ready for for action you take all the furniture you take your hammocks down the hammocks down you know the ships kind of serve as padding to kind of reinforce the the sides of the deck the men stripped the waist they sort of tie headband headbands or bandages around their heads so that will keep the sweat out and protect their eyes they do all that but then there's still an awful lot of waiting and actually on the british ships so we started this whole epic and i read that heart of oak i mean
对这场战役的精彩记述。特拉法尔加战役的这些惊人记述。它们之所以如此震撼，是因为那种紧张感在不断地累积、累积、累积，持续了一个又一个小时，所以他们清理了甲板，然后英国战舰——当你准备战斗时，你要把所有的家具搬走，把吊床拆下来，你知道的，这些战物在某种程度上起到了垫子的作用，用来加固甲板的两侧，男人们赤裸着上身，他们在头上系上头带或绷带，这样可以擦掉汗水并保护眼睛，他们做了所有这些，但随后仍然有大量令人煎熬的等待，实际上在英国战舰上，所以我们开始了整个这段史诗般的经历，我读到《橡树之心》，我的意思是
that's one of the songs they sing the band strikes up the bands are playing the bands are playing they sing rule britannia they're singing god King. At one point, they dance the hornpipe on board. Well, also, Dominic, for breakfast, they've been given wine. They have. Wine and meat. Yeah. Wine unusually. On Villeneuve's ship.
有一刻，他们在船上跳起了号笛舞。而且，多米尼克，作为早餐，他们还得到了葡萄酒。是的，他们得到了。葡萄酒和肉。是的。不同寻常地发了葡萄酒。在维尔纳夫的战舰上。
So the British are sort of singing Rue Britannia and dancing. On Villeneuve's ship, I was very pleased to read that he parades the Imperial Eagle. That's right. It's been given sent by by napoleon and the uh his his officers swear oaths of loyalty they renew their oaths of loyalty to the emperor so you know it's the perfect a british a sort of hogarth figure couldn't make this up you know the contrast between the sort of the high spirits of the british and the french swearing loyalty to an absolutist ruler.
因此，英国人一边唱歌一边跳着《不列颠尼亚统治吧》。而在维尔纳夫的战舰上，我非常高兴地读到，他检阅了帝国之鹰。没错。那是拿破仑派人送来的，他的军官们宣誓效忠，他们向皇帝重申效忠的誓言，所以你知道，这太完美了。一个英国式的、荷加斯（Hogarth）笔下的人物都编不出这样的情节，你知道的，英国人的高昂士气与法国人向专制君主宣誓效忠形成了鲜明的对比。
But I think there's a seaman on Victory who says, you know, we are like lions anxious to be at it. They are, they're keyed up for the battle, even though they know that lots of them are going to die. They seem to have a kind of battle frenzy. Whereas on one of the Spanish ships, one of the captains says the fleet is doomed. So there's a good, you know, very, what is it? The guy from dad's army. Yeah, we're doomed, doomed. Yeah, exactly. So anyway, so Nelson, they have this kind of, they've developed this signaling, which Nelson has been using to kind of convey orders. And they have this famous, Nelsonelson wants england confides that every man will do his duty this is the message he wants to convey confides meaning trust so england
但我认为“胜利号”上有一名水手说过，你知道的，我们就像渴望战斗的雄狮。他们确实如此，他们为了战斗已经高度亢奋，尽管他们知道他们中会有很多人牺牲。他们似乎有一种战斗狂热。而在其中一艘西班牙战舰上，一位船长却说舰队注定了。所以有一个很好的，你知道的，非常……那是谁？《爸爸的军队》（Dad's Army）里的那个家伙。对，我们死定了，死定了。对，完全如此。无论如何，纳尔逊他们有这种……他们已经发展出了一种信号系统，纳尔逊一直用它来传达命令。他们有这个著名的信号：纳尔逊希望英格兰指望每位官兵都恪尽职守。这是他想要传达的信息。“指望”的意思就是信任。所以英格兰
trusts that every man will do his duty but they don't have a signal for confides and so the signal says could we use expects yeah and so that's the message that goes up 31 flags it took to signal that message and And there were conflicting reports, but some say the men cheer. They raise a great cheer when they see this. Well, Collingwood thinks it's all a bit much. He complains that there are too many signals, that they know what to do. But then he reads the signal and he welcomes it as well. And hurrah, ready for battle. So slowly, slowly, slowly, the British fleet, pronged with Nelson and Collingwood, draw closer and closer and closer towards the enemy line. And a mile away, the French and Spanish start to fire. And the first shot flies over victory. And Nelson has two captains with him on board. And so he says, you know, chaps, time to go. Off you go. And they head off and he shakes the hands of one of the captains. And one of the captains takes Nelson's hand and said, I trust my Lord that on my return to the victory, which will be as soon as possible, I shall find your lordship well and in possession of 20 prizes on which he, Nelson, made this reply, God bless you, Blackwood. I shall never speak to you again.
相信每位官兵都会恪尽职守，但他们信号本里没有“指望”这个词，于是信号员问：我们可以用“期待”吗？是的，这就是发出的讯息。发送这个信号总共用了31面旗帜。有相互冲突的报道，但有人说水手们发出了欢呼。当他们看到这个时，爆发出了巨大的欢呼声。好吧，科林伍德觉得这一切有点小题大作。他抱怨说信号太多了，大家都知道该做什么。但随后他读了信号，也对此表示欢迎。乌拉，为战斗做好准备。于是，缓缓地、缓缓地、缓缓地，以纳尔逊和科林伍德为双尖的英国舰队，越来越近、越来越近、越来越近地逼近敌人的战列线。相距一英里时，法西联合舰队开始开火。第一发炮弹从“胜利号”上方呼啸掠过。纳尔逊身边带着两位舰长。于是他说，好了，伙计们，该走了。你们去吧。他们便出发了，他与其中一位舰长握了握手。其中一位舰长握住纳尔逊的手说：“我深信，大人，当我返回‘胜利号’时——这将是尽可能快的事情——我会看到阁下身体安康，并俘获20艘战利品。”对此，纳尔逊作出了这样的回答：“上帝保佑你，布莱克伍德。我将再也不会跟你说话了。”
So, yeah. Biographers have had enormous, you know, spent oceans of ink about that remark. Does Nelson feel, you know, the grim reaper peering over his shoulder? Or is this what captains, people often say before a battle in which so many people they know will be killed? And if they live, it's a remark that will be forgotten, but it lives on purely because he, I mean, who knows? Who knows? Well, so in the Victorian period where they were very agitated by his relationship with Lady Hamilton, it became part of the myth that he felt ashamed of his relationship with Emma and
所以，是的。传记作家们对这句话倾注了极大的心血、消耗了无数的笔墨。纳尔逊是否感觉到死神正从他的肩膀后窥视？还是说，这只是即将经历无数相识之人阵亡的战役前夕，人们经常说的话？如果他们活下来，这将是一句被遗忘的话，但它之所以流传下来，纯粹是因为他……我是说，谁知道呢？谁知道呢？好吧，在维多利亚时代，人们对他和汉密尔顿夫人（Lady Hamilton）的关系感到非常焦虑，这句话成了神话的一部分，人们认为他为自己与艾玛的关系感到羞耻，
was looking to re-burnish his relationship with Emma and was looking to re-burnish his sense of honor and was offering himself up as a sacrifice. And it is true that Nelson was obsessed with the death of James Wolfe at the Battle of Quebec in the Seven Years' War. And there was a famous painting by the American painter Benjamin West, who became president of the Royal Academy, who Nelson had met at Fonthill in Wiltshire, very near where I grew up and I played cricket there. And Beckford was, it was owned by William Beckford, who was a kind of plantation owner,
并渴望重塑自己的荣誉感，于是将自己作为祭品献了出来。确实，纳尔逊对七年战争中魁北克战役里詹姆斯·沃尔夫（James Wolfe）的死着了迷。美国画家本杰明·韦斯特（Benjamin West）曾画过一幅著名的画作，他后来成为了皇家艺术学院院长。纳尔逊曾在威尔特郡的方山（Fonthill）见过韦斯特，那里离我长大、打板球的地方非常近。那座庄园属于威廉·贝克福德（William Beckford），他是一个种植园主，
fabulously, dangerously rich sugar baron. And Nelson met West there and said, well, you know, why aren't you painting more canvases like the Death of Wolf? And West says, well, you know know why aren't you painting more canvases like uh like the death of wolf and west says well you know there aren't any heroes and nelson goes hmm but i don't i don't think i mean i think the consensus among those who who studied nelson is that he had no sense of a death wish i mean this was yeah he was not looking to sacrifice himself he was not looking to offer himself up as a blood sacrifice to britain or yeah to uh to exonerate his shame
是个极富且极其危险的糖业大亨。纳尔逊在那里遇到了韦斯特，并说道：“好吧，你知道的，你为什么不多画一些像《沃尔夫之死》这样的画布呢？”韦斯特回答说：“好吧，你知道的……你为什么不多画一些像《沃尔夫之死》这样的画布呢？”韦斯特说：“好吧，你知道的，现在已经没有什么英雄了。”纳尔逊听了“嗯”了一声。不过我不认为……我认为那些研究纳尔逊的学者们的共识是，他并没有寻死的念头。我的意思是，这……他并不是在寻求自我牺牲，他并不是想把自己作为血祭献给英国，或者……献给……以洗刷他的耻辱
or anything like that but you know it's it's a tense moment um and they are going into hell yeah we may it's basically we may we may never meet again isn't it i mean yeah nelson's quite a sentimental person he says very patriotic and sentimental things that meet again isn't it i mean yeah nelson's quite a sentimental person he says very patriotic and sentimental things that's how i perceive it i don't think he's because he thinks he's going to win i mean that's why he's devised the plan yeah i mean he's he's confident he's going to win but he also knows that that he is going as we say going into the jaws of hell and actually it's collingwoodwood rather than Nelson who hits the enemy first because the Royal Sovereign, Collingwood's flagship, has just had its hull newly coppered.
或诸如此类的事情。但你知道的，这是一个紧张的时刻……他们正步入地狱。是的，基本上就是：我们可能……我们可能再也无法相见了，不是吗？我的意思是，是的，纳尔逊是一个相当多愁善感的人，他说过非常爱国且感伤的话。再也无法相见了，不是吗？我的意思是，是的，纳尔逊是一个相当多愁善感的人，他说过非常爱国且感伤的话。这就是我的看法。我不认为他这么说是因为他觉得他会输。我的意思是，这就是他制定这个计划的原因。是的，我的意思是，他有信心自己会赢，但他也知道，正如我们所说，他正走向地狱之口。事实上，是科林伍德而不是纳尔逊率先打击了敌人，因为科林伍德的旗舰“皇家主权号”刚刚在船体上钉上了崭新的铜皮。
So it's very, very fast, gets ahead of Victory, gets ahead of the Belle Isle, which is the ship directly behind Collingwood. So it is first into the jaws of hell, then Victory as well. Collingwood is about two miles southeast of the victory and the cannon fire is starting to come. However, having said that, I think both Collingwood and Nelson know that it is not perhaps as dangerous as it might be, partly because the wind and the tide and the waves are against the enemy. So they're rolling up and down, up and down. Very difficult to get a kind of direct aim. However, I think that neither Collingwood nor
所以它的速度非常非常快，超过了“胜利号”，也超过了紧跟在科林伍德后面的“贝尔岛号”（Belle Isle）。因此它率先冲入地狱之口，紧接着“胜利号”也冲了进去。科林伍德在“胜利号”东南方约两英里处，炮火开始倾泻而话。然而话虽如此，我认为科林伍德和纳尔逊都知道，这或许并没有想象中那么危险，部分原因在于风向、潮汐和海浪对敌人不利。因此敌人（的战舰）在上下颠簸。很难进行直接瞄准。然而，我认为无论是科林伍德还是
Nelson are kind of suicidally brave. And even though the cannon fire is starting to smash into the sails, smash into the masts, all kinds of things, cannon fire is whistling past, they know that the swell is with them so the swell is is going with them it's moving them forward but this is disrupting the ability of the french and spanish ships to get a kind of steady aim because their ships are kind of rolling up and down up and down and that means that basically it you know it's only for a few seconds every minute that the ships are level and therefore the cannon are level. And so actually the fire that is coming from the French and Spanish line is pretty irregular and very inaccurate.
纳尔逊都不是那种具有自杀倾向的勇敢。尽管炮火开始击碎船帆、击断桅杆、各种东西……炮弹呼啸而过，但他们知道涌浪是顺着他们的方向的——涌浪与他们同行，推动着他们前进，但这却干扰了法西战舰稳定瞄准的能力，因为它们的船只在上下颠簸，这意味着基本上……只有每分钟中的短短几秒钟，船身是平稳的，因此加农炮才能水平对准。所以实际上，来自法西战列线的炮火相当不规则，而且非常不精准。
And on top of that, one of the technical advances that the British do have is that when they pull the trigger, it fires, whereas the French and Spanish have slow burning fuses. And that makes it even more difficult because if you're lighting a fuse that then has to kind of slow burn and the ship is rocking up and down i mean basically you know it's impossible to target your fire accurately still i mean it's not fun is it no even so the men the crew are told to you would generally lie flat on the deck if you're under fire except for the officers who are not allowed to do that basically so they are you know standing vertical targets for these whale of cannonballs that come sort of there's an unbelievably moving account from a a lieutenant on the bell isle which is the ship immediately
除此之外，英国人拥有的技术优势之一是：当他们扣动扳机时，火炮就会发射，而法国和西班牙使用的是缓慢燃烧的引信。这使得射击更加困难，因为如果你点燃一根引信，它需要慢速燃烧，而船只又在上下摇晃……我的意思是，基本上，你知道的，你根本无法准确瞄准你的火力。即便如此，情况也绝不好受。不，即便如此，船员们还是被告知……如果你在炮火下，你通常会平躺在甲板上，除了不允许这么做的军官们。所以他们基本上是……挺直身子站在那里，成为呼啸而来的密集的炮弹的活靶子。在紧跟在科林伍德旗舰后面的“贝尔岛号”上，有一位中尉写下了一段极其感人的叙事，也就是绝对身处最前沿的战舰。
behind collingwood's flagship so i mean absolutely in, absolutely in the front. And he's what, kind of 1920? He wrote after the battle, seeing that almost everyone was lying down, I was half disposed to follow the example and several times stoop for the purpose. But, and I remember the impression well, a certain monitor seemed to whisper, stand up and do not shrink from your duty. Turning around, my much esteemed and gallant senior fixed my attention. The serenity of his countenance and the composure with which he paced the deck drove more than half my terrors away and joining him i became somewhat infused with his spirit which cheered me on to act the part it became me and so that sense of being inspired by your senior officers is obviously terribly
他当时多大？19或20岁？他在战役结束后写道：“看到几乎所有人都躺下了，我也有了一半效仿的心思，并好几次弯下腰准备照做。但是——我至今对那种印象记忆犹新——内心某种指引似乎在低语：‘站起来，不要逃避你的职责。’回过转身，我备受尊敬且英勇的高级军官吸引了我的注意力。他面容的宁静以及他在甲板上踱步时的镇定，驱散了我过半的恐惧。我加入了他，内心的勇气也随之被他所感染，这激励我去扮演好我应当承担的角色。”因此，受到高级军官鼓舞的那种感觉显然极其重要，
important and that's why it's so important for n that he's prominent on the quarterdeck and that all appeals from his junior officers to him to. This is one from Ben Wilson's book, Empire of the Deep. And he says, for thousands of sailors on both sides, the battle was a glimpse into hell. The gun deck turned into a black and smoky furnace. Men slipped on the blood and viscera of their mess mates as they fought. To continue to man the guns in these conditions required the utmost courage. An officer remarked that the side effects of battle, temporary deafness, and the inability to see because of the gun smoke helped because they blotted out the noise and vision of messmates dying. All the men had to keep them sane and grounded was the mechanical rhythm of loading, hauling, firing. Hauling, loading, over and over and over.
这也是为什么对于纳尔逊来说，他在后甲板上表现得显眼至极，并且所有来自低阶军官的请求都……这段引自本·威尔逊（Ben Wilson）的书《深渊帝国》（Empire of the Deep）。书中写道：“对双方成千上万的水手来说，这场战役就是对地狱的一瞥。炮手甲板变成了浓烟滚滚的黑色熔炉。水手们在战斗时，脚下滑倒在战友的鲜血和内脏中。在这样的环境下继续操纵火炮，需要最大的勇气。一名军官评论说，战斗的副作用——暂时性聋哑，以及由于浓烟而无法视物——反倒帮了忙，因为它们屏蔽了战友死去的噪音和景象。所有能让水手们保持理智和镇定的，唯有装填、推炮、开火的机械节奏。推炮、装填，一遍又一遍，没完没了。”
But Dominic, I mean, remember, as they're approaching, they're not able to fire because they don't have a target. So they are sitting ducks, basically, aren't they? Until they can finally get to grips with the combined French and Spanish fleets when they finally pierce the line. Yeah, absolutely. And the closer they get, even with the swell and the slow burning fuses, the artillery, the cannon fire starts to generate casualties. So before Nelson reaches the French and Spanish line, his secretary, a man called Dr. Scott, is standing next to him, gets killed by a cannonball. Well, a cannonball that literally rips him in two. I mean, this is the extent of the horror.
但是，多米尼克，我的意思是，请记住，当他们逼近时，他们无法开火，因为他们没有目标。因此，基本上，他们就像待宰的羔羊，不是吗？直到他们最终突破战列线，与法西联合舰队短兵相接。是的，绝对如此。随着距离越来越近，尽管有涌浪和慢燃引信，炮火还是开始造成人员伤亡。因此，在纳尔逊抵达法西战列线之前，他的秘书——一个名叫斯科特（Dr. Scott）的人正站在他身旁，被一颗炮弹击中身亡。嗯，那颗炮弹字面意义上把他撕成了两半。我的意思是，恐怖程度达到了这种地步。
Yes. So it kind of takes off his body, doesn't it? His kind of legs are left standing there and then they collapse is that poor scott gone nelson asks and he gets and also the other thing is it's not just the cannibals it's splinters from the wood that are kind of firing everywhere and a splinter rips off the buckle of hardy's shoe which is kind of an amazing thing um eight marines get killed on on the deck of victory by a single shot. And Nelson says to Hardy, you know, this is warm work, warm work to last long. And he knows they've got to get up close and then they can start the killing.
是的。所以这炮弹直接带走了他的身体，不是吗？他的双腿留在原地，然后瘫倒在地。“可怜的斯科特死了吗？”纳尔逊问道，他得到了……而且另一件事是，不仅有炮弹，还有四处飞溅的木头碎片。一片木碎片削掉了哈迪（Hardy）鞋上的搭扣，这真是一件令人惊异的事……八名海军陆战队员在“胜利号”的甲板上被一发炮弹当场炸死。纳尔逊对哈迪说：“这是一场激烈的战斗，激烈的战斗不知能持续多久。”他知道他们必须靠得很近，然后才能开始杀戮。
And the ship that first does that is the Royal Sovereign. Collingwood on the Royal Sovereign closing in on the Santa Ana, which is under the command of de Alva, commanding the vanguard. Adam Nicholson describes this brilliant phrase in his book, the cold silence of the approaching British guns. And the only shot that Collingwood on the Royal Sovereign aims is a couple to create a kind of smoke screen, but he's still not fired a shot in anger. And it glides past the Santa Ana. Collingwood swings round and it passes under the windows of the stern of the Santa Ana. And now the Santa Ana is absolutely at its most vulnerable and Collingwood can rake the Santa Ana. And it's able to rake it basically for about a minute
率先做到这一点的战舰是“皇家主权号”。科林伍德率领“皇家主权号”逼近由前卫舰队指挥官德·阿尔瓦指挥的“圣安娜号”。亚当·尼科尔森（Adam Nicholson）在他的书中使用了一个绝妙的词组：“逼近的英国火炮那冰冷的沉默”。科林伍德在“皇家主权号”上瞄准发射的仅有的几发炮弹是为了制造某种烟幕，但他依然没有真正带着怒火开过一炮。它从“圣安娜号”旁滑过。科林伍德转舵，从“圣安娜号”的船尾窗户下方驶过。此刻，“圣安娜号”变得极其脆弱，科林伍德得以对“圣安娜号”进行纵射。它在驶过时能够对其进行大约一分钟的持续纵射。
as it drifts past. So just constant hell coming from the guns of the British ship, just ripping through the Santa Ana, basically. Because as I said, if you're aiming at the ribs of a ship, the side of a ship, you can't get through. But if you're aiming at it, it's kind of soft, it's open. You can aim artillery fire and it will go through all the decks right the way to the front of the ship and so that minute that the royal sovereign is drifting past the the um uh the stern of the
因此，来自英国战舰火炮的持续地狱般的轰击，直接撕裂了“圣安娜号”。因为正如我所说，如果你瞄准一艘船的船肋、船侧，你是无法击穿的。但如果你瞄准它（船尾），那里比较脆弱，是敞开的。你可以将炮火倾泻进去，炮弹将穿透所有甲板，一直打到船首。因此，在“皇家主权号”从“圣安娜号”船尾缓缓驶过的那一分钟里，
santa rana 240 of a crew of 800 are killed in the space of a minute yeah and and that is the impact of kind of close impact gunnery that is is the condition of chaos that Nelson has wanted to create. I mean, imagine the scene, Tom, the smoke. I mean, literally people's heads, body parts flying through the air, splinters. I mean, splinters would kill an enormous number of people, wouldn't they? Awful, awful. It's absolute chaos, absolute carnage. Obviously, the moment that the Royal Sovereign has drifted past,
800名船员中有240人在短短一分钟内丧生。这就是近距离集中炮击的威力，这也是纳尔逊一直想要制造的混乱状态。想象一下那个场景，汤姆，浓烟。我的意思是，字面意义上的人头、身体部位在空中飞舞，木片。我的意思是，木片会杀死巨量的人，不是吗？太可怕了，太可怕了。这是绝对的混乱，绝对的大屠杀。显然，“皇家主权号”刚一驶过，
more and more French and Spanish ships are kind of coming up, I suppose like bees in a hive that's been disturbed. They're firing muzzle to muzzle, hugely playing to the British advantage. I mean, lots and lots of British sailors are dying, but they're losing maybe 25%. The French and Spanish are losing 50%. And that's the margin of victory. Well, this is an interesting thing because this is that Nelson knew,
越来越多的法国和西班牙战舰便围了上来，我想就像受到惊扰的蜂巢里的蜜蜂一样。它们进行着枪口对枪口（零距离）的射击，这极大地符合了英国人的优势。我的意思是，成百上千的英国水手正在死去，但他们的损失率或许是25%。法国和西班牙的损失率则高达50%。这就是胜利的差距。好吧，这是一个有趣的问题，因为纳尔逊深知这一点，
and the whole strategy was based on the fact that the British gunnery was quicker, more effective, more efficient. So they know that as many as they are losing, if they're still firing, they will inflict more damage on the enemy than the enemy can ever possibly inflict on them so essentially those british casualties are the payment for the opportunity to force the surrender so by quarter past two in the afternoon santa ana has surrendered yeah so that the strategy is bloody it's brutal it costs a lot of british lives it costs even more lives french and spanish lives. But as far as the British are concerned, it works. Meanwhile, the head of the other line, Victory,
整个战略都建立在这样一个事实之上：英国的炮击速度更快、更有效、更高效。因此他们知道，尽管他们自己也在遭受损失，但只要他们继续开火，他们对敌人造成的破坏就会超过敌人可能对他们造成的破坏。因此，本质上，那些英国人的伤亡就是迫使敌方投降所需付出的代价。因此到下午两点一刻，“圣安娜号”已经投降了。是的，所以这个策略虽然血腥、残酷，它夺去了许多英国人的生命，但夺去的法兰西和西班牙人的生命更多。然而对英国人来说，它奏效了。与此同时，另一列纵队的领头船“胜利号”，
has reached the enemy. It aims first at the Santissima Trinidad, the largest ship in the world with its four decks, and then for the Boussaintour Villeneuve's flagship with the eagle that has been given to it by Napoleonoleon it again it rakes the uh the boost and tours stern just as collingwood had done nelson kills hundreds within that kind of you know that minute of concentrated lethal fire victory itself gets raked through its brow uh and that's the moment that that kills more people on board victory than any other. That's by the French ship Neptune or Spanish ship Neptune. That's right. French ship Neptune.
已经抵达敌人阵前。它首先瞄准了世界上面积最大、拥有四层甲板的“圣特立尼达号”，接着瞄准了维尔纳夫的旗舰“布桑托尔号”——上面插着拿破仑赠予的那面鹰旗。它再次对“布桑托尔号”的船尾进行了纵射，就像科林伍德所做的那样。纳尔逊在那一分钟集中且致命的猛烈炮火中杀死了数百人。“胜利号”自身的船首也被敌舰纵射了。这也是“胜利号”上人员伤亡最惨重的一刻。那是法国战舰“海王星号”（Neptune）或西班牙战舰“海王星号”干的。没错。法国战舰“海王星号”。
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. A ship called the Redoutable. Yes. Commanded by very, very brave, tough captain called Jean-Jacques Lucas blocks off victory's passage. So victory is essentially stationary. And there's a piece of iron that gets caught and essentially solders victory and Redoutable together so that the guns are just
是的。有一艘名为“可畏号”（Redoutable）的战舰。是的。由一位非常勇敢、强悍的舰长让-雅克·卢卡斯（Jean-Jacques Lucas）指挥，它挡住了“胜利号”的去路。因此“胜利号”基本上动弹不得。有一块铁钩住了它们，基本上将“胜利号”和“可畏号”焊接在了一起，双方的火炮在近距离上
firing away. Because otherwise, the force of the blast would have propelled victory away from Redoutable, but it doesn't. And this essentially is what dooms Nelson. Because Lucard and his men are desperate to board victory, but even though they can't do that, they're absolutely packed with musket men. And Lucard, recognizing that he can never outgun the British gunners, he locks up the portholes so that it gets harder for the British cannonballs to get through and relies on his muskets, his musketry, his soldiers. And that means a lot of musket balls firing. And 1.15 in the afternoon, probably, I mean, I don't know, maybe you'd say that the arrow that killed King Harold at Hastings is the most famous shot fired in British history. But this is is up there.
狂轰滥炸。因为如果没有这个卡住，爆炸的威力会把“胜利号”从“可畏号”身边推开，但事实并非如此。这基本上就是导致纳尔逊走向毁灭的原因。因为卢卡斯和他的部下迫切想要登上“胜利号”，尽管他们无法做到这一点，但船上挤满了火枪手。卢卡斯意识到自己的炮手永远无法在炮战中胜过英国人，于是他关上了炮门，这样英国人的炮弹就更难打进来了，并转而依靠他的火枪、火枪手和士兵。这意味着大量的火枪弹药在齐射。下午1点15分左右，也许……我不知道，也许你会说在黑斯廷斯战役中杀死哈罗德国王的那支箭是英国历史上发出的最著名的枪弹。但这绝对可以与之媲美。
This is certainly up there, isn't it? Probably first equal. The shot is fired that hits Nelson. And he falls on his left side right into the blood where John Scott had been killed. And he gets drenched in Scott's blood. So the decks are covered in sand to soak up the blood. And it's a measure of just how much carnage had been left by the destruction of Scott's upper body. The blood drenches Nelson. And he cries out, they've done for me at last.
这绝对是不相上下，不是吗？大概并列第一。击中纳尔逊的那颗子弹发射了。他倒在左侧，正好倒在约翰·斯科特（John Scott）丧生时流下的血泊中。他被斯科特的鲜血浸透了。所以甲板上铺满了沙子来吸干血迹。斯科特上半身被毁时留下的惨烈血量可见一斑。纳尔逊被鲜血浸透了。他大喊道：“他们终于把我干掉了。”
And Hardy, who's standing next to him, says, I hope not. And Nelson says, yes, my backbone is shot through. So he's fallen. He's been, the musket ball has hit him in his left shoulder gone through the epaulette and it's picked up fragments of fabric as it passes yeah and it goes down through his chest severs an artery i think round about his lung and then lodges it smacks into his backbone and lodges in his spine. And the force of it knocks him down onto his knees and men cluster around him.
站在他身旁的哈迪说：“但愿没有。”纳尔逊说：“不，我的脊椎被打穿了。”所以他倒下了。他被……那颗火枪弹击中了她的左肩，穿过了肩章，在穿过时还夹带了碎布料。是的，它穿透了他的胸膛，我记得大概切断了他肺部附近的一条动脉，然后卡了进去，狠狠地撞进他的脊椎并卡在脊柱里。冲击力将他撞倒在地，部下们纷纷围了上来。
Take him below deck. And yeah, so they realise he's got to go below deck straight away to the surgeon's cockpit. Four of them take him down the ladders. I mean, just imagine how unbelievably agonising that must have been to be carried down these ladders. And Nelson, of course, had lost his arm. It had been operated on. And one of the things that he specified before Trafalgar is fought is that the surgeons below deck should warm up their knives.
把他抬到甲板下去。是的，所以他们意识到他必须立刻被带到甲板下的外科手术舱。四个人把他抬下了梯子。我的意思是，想象一下，被抬着走下这些梯子该是多么令人难以置信的痛苦。纳尔逊当然已经失去了一臂。那是动过手术的。特拉法加海战打响前，他曾特意交代过的一件事就是：甲板下的外科医生应该把他们的手术刀先加热。
Because he remembered the chill of the iron. Yeah. So, Tom, I think we should take a break at this climactic moment and then come back after the break to talk about what happens to Nelson and what happens in the battle. In the battle, yeah. So we'll see you in a couple of minutes. I'm Marina Hyde.
因为他记得铁器冰冷的触感。所以，汤姆，我想我们应该在这个高潮时刻暂停一下，休息过后，再来谈谈纳尔逊的结局以及战役的走向。战役的结局，是的。那么我们几分钟后见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com.
我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是您每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、八卦猛料的节目，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，向您讲述这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果您想要无广告收听、加更节目并提前获得现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。
So welcome back to the rest is history for this final concluding part of our trafalgar epic and tom uh before the break uh nelson was hit by a sniper from radio table nelson has been taken below decks uh to the surgeon dr beatty but meanwhile the battle of trafalgar is raging and it is clear i think at this point that nelson's plan is working yes because it's ironically because everything is totally unclear no one really has any idea what's going on it's absolute carnage ships are all kind of piling into it what one onto one another but this is playing to british strengths and they just devastate the uh the the french and spanish ships more and more carnage um ships smeared with blood um you know sloshing all over. I mean, literally sloshing over the, over the decks, just unspeakable. And by 140. So that's what,
欢迎回到《历史的余烬》，收听我们特拉法加史诗的最后结语。汤姆，在休息之前……纳尔逊被“可畏号”上的狙击手击中了，纳尔逊被带到了甲板下，送到了外科医生比蒂（Dr. Beatty）那里。但与此同时，特拉法加海战正在激烈进行，此时看来，纳尔逊的计划显然正在奏效。是的，因为具有讽刺意味的是，由于一切都完全一片模糊，没有人真正知道发生了什么，这是一场绝对的大屠杀，战舰一艘接一艘地撞在一起，但这完全符合英国人的优势，他们不断重创法西联合舰队。更多的大屠杀……战舰上涂满了鲜血……你知道的，血水到处泼洒。我的意思是，字面意义上的血水洒满了甲板，简直无法言说。到了1点40分。也就是……
that's almost half an hour after Nelson has been shot on the deck of victory. Villeneuve on the Boussaintour surrenders. And before he surrenders, he makes sure that the Eagle that has been given him by Napoleon is, is thrown overboard. And an hour after Nelson is shot, victory at last drifts away from Redoutable. So Redoutable, to give you a sense of the carnage,
那是纳尔逊在“胜利号”甲板上中枪后大约半小时。维尔纳夫在“布桑托尔号”上投降了。在投降之前，他确保拿破仑赠予他的那只鹰标被扔进了海里。在纳尔逊中枪一小时后，“胜利号”终于从“可畏号”身边缓缓漂离开来。因此，“可畏号”上——为了让你对这场大屠杀有个概念。
Redoutable had a crew of 643 men, and 300 of those men are killed, and 222 of them are wounded, and many of those wounds are pretty severe. So that gives you a i mean basically the vast majority of the men on that ship are either killed or very very badly injured i mean you just the horror of fighting at sea is is so often i think underestimated well that's and that's the brutal reality of nelson's ambition to fight a war of annihilation yeah um you know i consider
“机敏号”有643名船员，其中300人阵亡，222人受伤，许多伤势相当严重。所以这就告诉你——我的意思是，基本上船上绝大多数人要么阵亡，要么伤势极其严重。我的意思是，海上作战的残酷性往往被大大低估了。没错，这就是纳尔逊发动歼灭战的残酷现实。
the destruction of the enemy's fleet of so much consequence that i would willingly have half of mine burnt to affect their destruction and and it works that's the bargain that he's made yeah you look at the stats you look at the figures so of nelson's men 460 of them or so were killed and about 1200 injured200 injured. But of the French and Spanish, of those killed, wounded, or captured, the total is 14,000. So that is a testament. I mean, everything we talked about, particularly in episode one, about the efficiency, the ruthless efficiency of the Royal Navy
是的，嗯……你知道的，我认为摧毁敌方舰队具有如此重大的意义，以至于我愿意烧掉我的一半舰队来换取他们的毁灭。而且，这确实奏效了，这就是他做出的交易。是的，你看看统计数据，看看这些数字：纳尔逊的手下大约有460人阵亡，大约1200人受伤——200人受伤。但在法军和西盟方面，无论是阵亡、受伤还是被俘，总数达到了14,000人。所以这是一个证明。我的意思是，我们讨论过的一切，特别是在第一集里关于皇家海军作为一台杀戮机器的高效，冷酷的高效。
as a killing machine. I mean, Trafalgar is the ultimate testament to that, isn't it? Because they go straight into the battle as you said muzzle to muzzle and it's the british who emerge by a gigantic margin 10 i mean 10 times the french and spanish lose 10 times yeah the the british losses but of course among the british losses um is probably the most famous man in Britain, Horatio Nelson himself. And even as the Boussaintour and other ships, French and Spanish ships, are surrendering, Nelson can feel that he's paralyzed.
我的意思是，特拉法尔加海战就是这方面的终极证明，对吧？因为正如你所说，他们直接杀入战场，炮口对炮口，最终大获全胜的是英国人，法军和西军的损失是英国人的整整十倍——我的意思是，十倍。是的，英国人确实也有损失，但英国人的损失中，嗯，可能包括了英国最著名的人物——霍雷肖·纳尔逊本人。甚至当“不屈号”和其他法西军舰正在投降时，纳尔逊已经感觉到自己瘫痪了。
He's seen what happens when someone gets shot in the spine. He's witnessed it for himself. He knows what's happening to him. The doctors try and cheer him up and say, oh, you'll be all right, my lord. But he says, no, no, no. And of course, he's lost control over his bodily functions so he's urinating shitting um bleeding he says to the doctor straight away dr beatty i mean this is classic nelson he says ah mr beatty you can do nothing for me i have but a short time to live my back is shot through and he says to beat, don't worry about me. Look after your other patients.
他见过脊椎中枪的人是什么样的，他亲眼目睹过。他知道自己身上发生了什么。医生们试图让他振作起来，说：“哦，阁下，你会好起来的。”但他说：“不，不，不。”当然，他已经失去了对身体机能的控制，所以他在小便、大便、流血。他立刻对医生说：“贝蒂医生——”我的意思是，这真是典型的纳尔逊风格，他说：“啊，贝蒂先生，你对我无能为力了，我时日无多，我的后背被打穿了。”他对贝蒂说：“别管我，照顾好你的其他病人。”
And then he says constantly, Doctor, I'm gone, I'm gone. And he starts saying, remember me to Lady Hamilton. I have made a will. I have left Lady Hamilton and Horatio to my country. I mean, this line is a sort of obsession for him that Emma Hamilton and their daughter will not be looked after. And it's about, I think, 2.30 that Captain Hardy, who as you described Hardy, Tom, earlier on, I mean, Hardy is a huge man, isn't he?
然后他不断地说：“医生，我快不行了，我快不行了。”他开始说：“代我向汉密尔顿夫人问好。我立了遗嘱。我把汉密尔顿夫人和霍雷肖托付给我的国家。”我的意思是，这句话对她来说是一种执念，担心艾玛·汉密尔顿和他们的女儿得不到照顾。我想大概在两点半左右，哈迪舰长——就像你刚才描述的那样，汤姆，哈迪是一个身材魁梧的人，对吧？
Six foot four or something. He's balding, stooping. Yeah. Yeah. Very, very kind of striking figure, very stern disciplinarian, but devastated by, I mean, adores Nelson. Yes. And is absolutely devastated to see him dying. And come down to stay with Nelson about 3.30.
身高六尺四寸左右。他有点驼背，秃顶。是的。是的，非常非常引人注目的身材，纪律严明，但心碎欲绝——我的意思是，他崇拜纳尔逊。是的，看到纳尔逊垂死，他心碎欲绝。大约三点半，他下来陪纳尔逊。
So that's just over a couple of hours after he's been shot. So Nelson takes quite a, for someone who's so badly injured, Tom, what struck me about this was I had, before I read up on it i had this sort of vague idea that nelson is shot he's taken downstairs and then he dies no it's very protracted it's very protracted so he's in agony for for hours asking for lemonade or asking to be fanned being given wine constantly saying you know i i have he says again and again i leave lady hamilton and horatio so that's one obsession and the other obsession of course is how is the battle going so when hardy comes down he's saying um you know how goes the battle how goes the day with us
所以这大约是在他中枪两个多小时后。所以纳尔逊受了这么重的伤，汤姆，让我震惊的是，在我了解相关情况之前，我有一种模糊的想法：纳尔逊中枪了，他被抬到舱下，然后他就死了。不，过程非常漫长，非常漫长。所以他在痛苦中煎熬了几个小时，要求喝柠檬水，要求有人扇扇子，不断被喂酒，一遍又一遍地说：“我知道我——”他说，“我把汉密尔顿夫人和霍雷肖托付给……”所以这是一个执念，而另一个执念当然是战况如何？所以当哈迪下来时，他说：“嗯……战况如何？我们今天的战况怎么样？”
and hardy is able to say we've got about 12 or 14 of the enemy ships um and nelson's anxious that you know have the british lost any ships and says no um and so so he has that tough he has that but also going that but you talked about nelson and his attention to detail his perfectionism at one point later on when when hardy comes down you know the second time isn't it yeah but when he comes down and he says how many and? And Hardy says, very emotionally, you know, he knows the gravity of the moment. He says, you have won a complete victory. I'm certain that it's 14 or 15 of the enemy ships have surrendered. Now, we talked about the Battle of the Nile.
哈迪能够回答说：“我们俘获了大约12或14艘敌舰……”纳尔逊很担心英国是否失去了舰艇，哈迪回答说没有。所以他得到了这个，但他也有——而且你谈到了纳尔逊对细节的关注、他的完美主义。后来当哈迪第二次下来的时候，不是吗？是的，当他下来问：“有多少艘？”哈迪非常激动地回答——他知道这一刻的分量——他说：“你取得了彻底的胜利。我确定有14或15艘敌舰已经投降了。”现在，我们讨论过尼罗河战役。
How many ships had they sunk then? They'd sunk about two. Yeah. So this is a titanic. Unprecedented. Unbelievable victory. And Nelson says, that is well, but I bargained for 20. You know, that sort of drive, even at the last.
那时他们击沉了多少艘船？他们击沉了两艘左右。是的。所以这是一场轰轰烈烈的、史无前例的、难以置信的胜利。纳尔逊说：“这很好，但我原本指望的是20艘。”你知道，那种拼劲，即使在生命的最后一刻也是如此。
And then, of course, he says, take care of poor Lady Hamilton. And then there was this thing that schoolboys for generations in Britain have giggled about where he says, kiss me, Hardy. So Hardy leans forward and kisses him on the cheek and tom do you know the story about oberon war i know this is a slight um uh no this is an unexpected turn it is son uh son of even war the novelist he's was well known particularly well known in britain late 20th century great satirist writer for private eye oberon warded his national service and uh i think he was fiddling with a gun in cyprus or something
然后，当然，他说：“照顾好可怜的汉密尔顿夫人。”接着还有一件事，英国一代又一代的男校学生听到都会窃笑，那就是他说：“吻我，哈迪。”于是哈迪向前倾身，吻了他的脸颊。汤姆，你知道奥伯伦·沃（Oberon Waugh）的故事吗？我知道这有点……不，这是一个意想不到的转折。小说家奥伯伦·沃的儿子，他在20世纪后期的英国非常著名，是一位伟大的讽刺作家、《私家侦探》杂志的撰稿人。奥伯伦·沃在塞浦路斯服国家兵役时，我想他当时在玩弄一把枪什么的，
and the gun went off and and a burst of sort of machine gun fire or something went into him and he was convinced he was dying he's kind of lies on the ground blood seeping out of him and over on war was a man steep you know he'd read lots of history and he said to his second in command or whatever kiss me chudley right and this bloke just stared at him but unfortunately obram will then lived and he said that from that point onward some suspicion with deep deep suspicion because they didn't get the reference anyway so but hardy hardy actually kisses nelson twice doesn't he he does kisses him on the cheek and then um he kisses him on the forehead and nelson by this point is so far gone that he doesn't know who it is and he asks who it is and
结果枪走火了，一阵机枪扫射什么的打中了他。他确信自己快要死了，躺在地上，鲜血直流。奥伯伦·沃是个博览群史的人，他读过很多历史，于是他对副指挥官或者什么人说：“吻我，查德利（Chudley）。”结果那家伙只是瞪着他。不过不幸的是，奥伯伦·沃后来活了下来，他说从那以后他对周围人充满了深深的怀疑，因为他们根本没听懂这个梗。不管怎样，哈迪实际上吻了纳尔逊两次，不是吗？是的，他吻了他的脸颊，然后……嗯，他吻了他的额头，而此时的纳尔逊已经神志不清，他甚至不知道是谁在吻他，便问那是谁。
it is hardy god bless you i was so moving god bless you i mean of course like all other nine year olds when i came across this in my school textbook we all sort of giggled and said golly kiss me hardy what's going on there but um you know to read these descriptions now in the accounts of trafalgar it's it's incredibly moving um and then nelson in absolute i mean he always has this hollywood quality yeah and he really does in about 4 30 he's dying and his last word and there are different accounts he either says thank god i have done my duty which he has said again and again or some people some witnesses said his last words were god and my country but both i mean box office aren't they i'm determined that they will be my last words well i hope someone is on hand to yeah to record
那是哈迪。“上帝保佑你。”真是太感人了。“上帝保佑你。”我的意思是，当然，就像其他9岁的小孩一样，当我在学校课本里看到这一幕时，我们都窃笑说：“天哪，吻我，哈迪，那里在发生什么？”但是，嗯……现在在关于特拉法尔加海战的记录中读到这些描述，真的是极其感人。然后纳尔逊在绝对——我的意思是，他身上总有一种好莱坞式的特质。是的，他确实有。大约在4点30分，他快要死了，他的遗言有不同的版本：他要么说“感谢上帝，我尽了我的职责”（他这句话说过好多次），或者一些目击者说他的遗言是“上帝和我的祖国”。但这两句——我的意思是，都很有票房号召力，对吧？我决心让它们成为我的遗言。好吧，我希望当时有人在旁边记录下来。
so that's about so that's about 4 30 by which point it point it's very, you know, Nelson dies knowing that he has won the battle. All kinds of great prizes have been taken, including the Santissima Trinidad. A horrific description of the boarding party. So there's a ship, the Africa, that thinks that the Santissima Trinidad has, has surrendered. Boarding party goes on and a mission and British mission describes it. She had between three and 400 killed and wounded. Her beams were covered with blood,
所以那是大约4点30分，到了这个时候，纳尔逊带着赢得胜利的信念离世了。各种巨大的战利品被缴获，其中包括“三位一体”号（Santissima Trinidad）。对登船队的恐怖描述：有一艘名为“非洲”号的船，以为“三位一体”号已经投降了。登船队登上去执行任务，一名英国任务人员对其进行了描述：它有三到四百人伤亡，船梁上沾满了鲜血、
brains and pieces of flesh and the after part of her decks with wounded, some without legs and some without an arm. What calamities war brings on. Because the British, unless you're Nelson, the casualties get thrown overboard. The French and Spanish don't. They leave them there. But it turns out when the boarding party land on the Santissima Trinidad that actually they haven't surrendered, that they were just taking a a breather break and the um the uh the lieutenant who's led the boarding party apologizes and withdraws and it's all very
脑浆和碎肉，甲板后方躺满了伤员，有的人失去了双腿，有的人失去了一臂。战争带来了何等残酷的灾难！因为英国人——除非你是纳尔逊——伤员都会被直接扔进海里。法军和西班牙人则不然，他们把伤员留在船上。但事实证明，当登船队登上“三位一体”号时，他们其实并没有投降，他们只是在喘口气休息一下。率领登船队的英国中尉随后道了歉并撤了回来，整个过程表现得非常、非常得体。
very good behavior um it's all it's basically just bravado it's it's bravado because there's you know there's nothing the santissimo trinidad can done uh and in due course it gets captured and taken in tow with a great cargo of dead. So basically all the French and Spanish ships either get sunk or most of them get captured. The only ones that don't are the ships under Dumanoir, who is in command of the rear guard. Right, yes. And he doesn't engage. And it's unclear why he doesn't. Some said it was cowardice. Some said that he wanted to preserve something of the ship. And the only ship that does, from his rear guard,
这基本上只是虚张声势，纯粹是虚张声势，因为“三位一体”号当时已经无可奈何了，随后它被俘获，并带着堆积如山的尸体被拖走。所以基本上所有的法西军舰要么被击沉，要么绝大部分被俘获。唯一没有被俘的是由后卫指挥官迪马努瓦（Dumanoir）率领的舰队。没错，是的。他没有参战。目前还不清楚他为什么没有参战。有人说是懦弱，有人说他是想保留一些船只。而他的后卫部队中唯一参战的船只，
is a ship commanded by a French captain with the splendid name of Louis Inferné, who commands the Atrapide, plunges into the heart of battle, fights with absolutely suicidal bravery. And when the crew, you know, I mean, they're all kind of dead or dying and they finally agree to surrender. Inferné is so furious that they're surrendering that he has to be held down. And the British are unbelievably impressed by this and say that it deserves to be recorded in the memory of those who admire true heroism. And actually, the British are very, very impressed with how bravely the French and Spanish have fought.
是一艘由法国船长指挥的军舰，船名非常响亮，叫路易·安菲尔内（Louis Infernet），他指挥“不屈”号（L'Intrépide）直插战场中心，以绝对自杀式的勇敢进行战斗。当船员们——你知道的，基本上都死伤殆尽，最后同意投降时，安菲尔内愤怒至极，甚至试图阻止他们投降，最后不得不被人按住。英国人对此感到无比震撼，认为这值得被那些崇拜真正英雄主义的人铭记在心。事实上，英国人对法西军队作战的英勇表现感到非常、非常钦佩。
They're surprised, aren't they? Because they thought they slightly underestimated the French and Spanish, i think it's fair to say but the victory is total and um it's marked at 5 30 so an hour after nelson has died when one of the french ships literally explodes um that's the yeah and that is the end of you know the battle five and a half hours and it is well it's an absolutely thumping victory yes it is so the the previous record for uh you know a naval battle was was the one that nelson had got at the nile you mentioned that yeah which was seven captured and four destroyed um and uh the british have taken 12 ships as prizes and one has blown up and also they take over 11 000 prisoners um as it turns out, so two things slightly cast a shadow on the victory at Trafalgar. One, of course, is the death of Nelson.
他们很惊讶，不是吗？因为我认为可以公平地说，他们先前稍微有些轻视法西军队。但胜利是彻底的，嗯……标志性的时刻定格在下午5点30分——也就是纳尔逊去世一个小时后，其中一艘法国战舰轰然爆炸，那就是……是的，那就是战争的结束——历时五个半小时，这是一场绝对震撼的胜利。是的，确实如此。在此之前，海战的最高纪录是纳尔逊在尼罗河战役中创下的，你提到过，对吧？当时俘获了7艘，击毁了4艘。而现在英国人将12艘舰船作为战利品收入囊中，1艘爆炸沉没，此外他们还俘虏了11,000多名战俘。
The other is the fact that this swell that people had noticed in the early hours of the battle does indeed presage a storm. And this absolutely hits the Bay of Cadiz and Trafalgar and down to Gibraltar, causes absolute chaos. Lots of the prizes are sunk. One of the things that's actually very, very impressive and the British behave very well is that rather than just abandoning the French and Spanish prisoners on these ships, they risk their lives to save them. There's no example of British sailors abandoning their prisoners to their fate. And it's thought that maybe, it's thought that perhaps 2,000 drown in the storm.
正如事后所证明的那样，有两件事给特拉法尔加的胜利蒙上了一层淡淡的阴影。第一件事，当然是纳尔逊的逝世。另一个事实是，战役初期人们注意到的巨浪确实预示着一场风暴的到来。这场风暴狠狠地袭击了加的斯湾、特拉法尔加一直到直布罗陀，造成了绝对的混乱。许多战利品战舰沉没了。其中一件非常、非常令人印象深刻且英国人表现得极为高尚的事情是，他们并没有抛弃这些船上的法西战俘，而是冒着生命危险去营救他们。没有一个英国水手抛弃战俘任由他们自生自灭的例子。据估计，可能有多达2,000人在风暴中溺水身亡。
They rescue, from the Santissima Trinidad, they rescue a dog, a pug. So Collingwood would have approved of that with his love of dogs. And they end up actually only saving four prizes. And this, of course, is very bad news for everyone in the fleet because prizes, what do prizes mean? Prizes mean cash. Yes. Yeah, they do.
他们从“三位一体”号上救出了一只狗，一只哈巴狗。科林伍德一定会赞同这一做法，因为他非常喜欢狗。最终，他们实际上只抢救回了四艘战利品船。这对于舰队里的每个人来说无疑是个大坏消息，因为战利品意味着什么？战利品意味着现金。是的。确实如此。
They absolutely do. If you've ever read the Patrick O'Brien books, you know that they obsess for prizes. That's what they're after. Yeah. do if you've ever read the patrick o'brien books you know that they they they obsess that's what they're after yeah so parliament recognizes this and actually coughs up money to try and make up the short form oh that's good that's good form that's unusually good political form yes so good behavior from the british sailors in the aftermath of the battle good behavior from from uh from parliament so you were talking about the shadow so So the news doesn't reach England until, I think, about the 5th, 6th of November. And what's remarkable is that this crushing victory,
它们绝对意味着现金。如果你读过帕特里克·奥布莱恩（Patrick O'Brien）的小说，你就会知道他们对战利品有着怎样的执念。那正是他们梦寐以求的。是的。如果你读过帕特里克·奥布莱恩的书，你就会知道他们有多痴迷——那是他们想要的。所以议会意识到了这一点，实际上掏出了资金来试图弥补损失。哦，这很好，这很大方，这是罕见的好政风。是的，英国水手在战役结束后表现良好，议会也表现良好。所以你刚才在谈论阴影……所以消息直到11月5日或6日左右才传到英国。引人注目的是，这场压倒性的胜利——
this victory which really you could argue, I mean, we'll come to the significance of the battle in just a second, but you could argue it's decisive, not merely in the Napoleonic Wars, but in the course of the entire 19th century. People greet it with, I mean, they're as struck by the tragedy of the death of Nelson as they are by the glory of the triumph. So Pitt, William Pitt the Younger, he can't sleep when he's told.
这场胜利甚至可以说——我们一会儿就会谈到这场战役的意义——你甚至可以说它不仅在拿破仑战争中具有决定性意义，而且在整个19世纪的进程中都具有决定性意义。人们对它的反应——我的意思是，他们为纳尔逊逝世的悲剧所震撼，其程度不亚于他们为胜利的荣耀而欢欣鼓舞。因此，小威廉·پیت（William Pitt the Younger）在得知消息时彻夜难眠。
He's told about the victory. He gets up at 3 o'clock in the morning. Cause he can't, he can't sleep. He's so upset about the death of Nelson. The King, um, sits in silence, you know, unable to speak,
当他被告知胜利的消息时，他在凌晨3点就起床了。因为他睡不着，他为纳尔逊的死感到无比难过。国王静静地坐在那里，一句话也说不出来，
not, not cause of for once, not cause of madness, but because of grief, can I say, um, because of grief about Nelson's death. Uh,
这一次不是因为发疯，而是因为悲伤——请允许我这么说——是因为对纳尔逊之死的悲伤。
when people gather at the Admiralty buildings for news, they stay here, the news, and they stand there in a sort of a somber, broken silence because Nelson was such a hero to them. And then Nelson's body, when it's finally brought back, so Nelson's body had been kept in a barrel with spirits. A cask of brandy, isn't it? Brandy and then replaced with wine, I think. With wine, yeah. And he lies in state in Greenwich in the painted hall if anyone hasn't been to the
当人们聚集在海军部大楼等待消息时，他们听到了消息，然后站在那里，陷入了一种阴郁、心碎的沉默，因为纳尔逊对他们来说是如此伟大的英雄。后来，当纳尔逊的遗体终于被运回国时——纳尔逊的遗体一直被保存在烈酒的酒桶中。一桶白兰地，对吧？白兰地，后来据说换成了葡萄酒。换成了葡萄酒，是的。他停灵在格林尼治的彩绘大厅（Painted Hall）里。如果有人没去过格林尼治的彩绘大厅，那绝对是最不可思议的建筑。我的意思是，海军的宏伟壮丽在那座宏大的格林尼治建筑群中得到了完美的体现。随后，他享受了国葬——那是当时历史上规模最大的国葬。葬礼没有在威斯敏斯特教堂举行，而在圣保罗大教堂，是的，是在圣保罗大教堂举行，而且他被安葬在一个……是红衣主教沃尔西的棺木里吗？是的。
painted hall in greenwich it is the most extraordinary building i mean the magnificence and of the navy is sort of embodied isn't it in the the complex great complex at greenwich and then he has a state funeral at that point the biggest state funeral in history and it's not in westminster abbey in st paul's which yeah it's in st paul's and it's not in Westminster Abbey in St Paul's which yeah it's in St Paul's and it's kind of and he's buried in is it Cardinal Wolsey's it is coffin yes
那是为红衣主教沃尔西建造的棺木，是的。你知道，那是一个极其宏大的场面，到处都是来自“胜利号”的水兵们撕扯着旗帜的情景，
built for Cardinal Wolsey yeah and you know it's a massive scene and there's all kinds of stuff with men from the victory ripping up flags
或者说非常感人。好吧，这是一个英国以国葬和排场办得一团糟而“闻名”的时代，
or you know sort of very moving well so this is an age when Britain is is notorious for being absolutely hopeless at state funerals and you know pomp yeah so anyone who watched the queen's
所以任何看过女王葬礼的人可能会惊讶地发现，英国曾经是这类事情的代名词——毫无效率可言。但对于纳尔逊，他们真的是倾尽全力，结果取得了巨大的成功。你知道谁出席了葬礼吗？是可怜的老维尔纳夫（Villeneuve）。哦，不。他被带了回去。他被送到了雷丁。作为惩罚。
funeral may be surprised to know that britain was a byword for uselessness at this kind of thing but nelson they really pull the stops out and it's it's a great success um and you know who's there at the funeral is uh poor poor old Villeneuve. Oh, no. He's been taken back. He's been sent to Reading. Right. As punishment.
他被关在那里当囚犯。然后他不得不出席葬礼。接着，可怜的人，他在1806年被送回了法国，显然他的结局不会太好。他被发现时已经死亡，关于他是被谋杀还是自杀引发了激烈的争论。汤姆，他当时不如留在雷丁呢。
He's kept there as a prisoner. And then he has to attend the funeral. And then poor man, he gets sent back to France in 1806. And it's clearly not going to end well with him. And he's found dead. And there's much debate as to whether he is murdered or commits suicide. He would have been better off staying in Reading, Tom.
我很少说这句话。是的，他确实应该留下。但有趣的是，法国报纸《消息报》（Le Moniteur）对特拉法尔加海战却只字未提。他们甚至提都没提。不，没有提及。天哪。
It's not often I say that phrase. Yes, he would have been. But interestingly, there's absolutely no mention of Trafalgar whatsoever in the French press. Le Moniteur. They don't even mention it. No, not mentioned. Oh, dear.
只字未提。海军战役的结果不一定对我们有利。那就别提。一个字也别说。所以关于它的意义：许多拿破仑战争的历史学家曾提出过一种观点，即这场海战实际上什么也没改变。是的。但在1806年，布雷斯特（Brest）有两支舰队驶出，在随后的十年里，
Not mentioned. The naval campaign has worked out not necessarily to our advantage. It doesn't. Don't say a word. So the significance of it. So there is a case which has been made by lots of historians of Napoleonic wars that actually it changes nothing. Yeah. But in 1806, there are two squadrons from breast that go out uh that over the course of the decade that
拿破仑一直在不断建造新船——我想到了1814年他又造了大约100艘船——似乎一切都没有真正改变。但我认为其意义绝对是巨大的。我的意思是，布雷斯特的那两支舰队很快就被消灭了；拿破仑基本上沦落到试图从其他大国那里强夺船只的地步——这就是第二次哥本哈根战役，对吧？英国人进军夺取了丹麦的船只。而且完全可以说，重建海军的野心扭曲了拿破仑的整个地缘政治战略。正是这一点导致他将矛头指向了他在特拉法尔加的盟友西班牙并入侵了它。而这就演变成了半岛战争的灾难。从长远来看，这某种程度上导致了他入侵俄国。
follows napoleon is is endlessly building new ships um i think by 1814 he has another about 100 ships uh that nothing really changes i think the significance is absolutely enormous i mean those two squadrons from breast get finished off very rapidly um napoleon is reduced basically to trying to grab ships off other power so that's the second battle of copenhagen yeah uh when the british go in and grab the uh the danish ships and there's a case for saying, isn't there, that the ambition to essentially reconstruct a navy distorts Napoleon's entire geopolitical strategy. It's what leads him to turn on Spain, his ally at Trafalgar, and to invade it. And that becomes the disaster of the Peninsular War. And in the long run, it kind of leads him to invade Russia.
确实如此，因为接下来发生的是，皇家海军现在可以在没有法西舰队挑战的情况下对欧洲实施海上封锁。拿破仑提出了“大陆体系”的想法，试图将英国人挡在欧洲之外，把英国的进口商品排挤出去等等。但实际上，多年来，海军对欧洲大陆实施了封锁，夺取了欧洲大部分地区的商船贸易，控制了海岸线和商业。因此，作为一个大陆帝国的拿破仑帝国正在逐渐被挤压。为了坚持将其他欧洲大国拖入他的体系，他将矛头指向了俄国。这在某种程度上就是战争的借口。他希望俄国人对英国船只关闭港口，但他们拒绝这样做。1812年的战役……所有这一切，在某种程度上都源于1805年的那场失败。
It does, because what happens is that the Royal Navy can now enforce a blockade of Europe, unchallenged by a French and Spanish fleet. Napoleon has this idea of the continental system to try and keep the British out of Europe, to get British imports out and so on. But effectively, over the years, the Navy has this blockade of the continent. It seizes the merchant marine trade of most of Europe, dominates the coast, dominates commerce. So Napoleon's empire, which is a continental empire, is gradually being squeezed. In his insistence on dragging other European powers into his system, he turns on Russia. That's the casus belli to some extent. He wanted the Russians to close their ports to British ships, and they wouldn't do it. The campaign of 1812. All of this flows from, to some extent, from that defeat in 1805.
正如你之前所说，1805年还带来了另一个结果：当战争结束时，英国拥有了它所有的殖民地，控制了海上航线，控制了商船队，控制了国际商业，它处于极其有利的地位，能够从和平岁月中获益，并建立起其帝国的商业霸权。所以我觉得这一切，可以说——当然，当然我们应该说，在特拉法尔加，当时存在着三种不同类型的社会。有西班牙的旧制度（Ancien Régime）。有法国的革命共和国。
And as you said beforehand, what 1805 also does is it means that when the war is over, Britain has all its colonies. It has control of the sea lanes. It has control of the merchant marine. It has control of international commerce and it is it is it is supremely well placed to benefit from the in the years of peace and to build up its kind of imperial commercial supremacy so i think all of that arguably and of course and of course one should say that you know trafalgar there were three different types of society. There's the Ancien Régime of Spain. There was the Revolutionary Republic of France.
还有那种……宪政君主制……英国的工业资产阶级君主制。但本质上，支撑全球工业化和资本主义的框架，可以说是在这之后奠定的。如果没有海军对海洋的控制，废除奴隶贸易是不可能由海军强制执行的。所以这就是我对特拉法尔加的看法：一方面，它是英国现代性的胜利。它是高度纪律严明的海军的胜利，是经过千锤百炼的炮手团队的胜利，这一切都需要资金，这是官僚体制的胜利。它是皮特、金融、税收、政府借贷体系以及所有这些事物的胜利。这是一个日益工业化和金融化的社会的胜利。然而，正如你所说——而且我认为你绝对是对的——它也是一个属于荷马史诗般传说的故事，因为纳尔逊的牺牲和胜利的时刻，以及这个总是把自己视为——正如你所说的那样——你管他叫什么来着？基督教阿基里斯？克里斯蒂安·阿基里斯，是的。
And there was the kind of- Constitutional monarchy of- Industrial bourgeois constitutional monarchy of Britain. But essentially, the frameworks that will underpin global industrialization and capitalism are laid, you could argue, in the abolition of the slave trade would have been impossible for the Navy to enforce had they not had domination of the seas. So here's the thing about Trafalgar, I would say. I'd say on the one hand, it's the victory of British modernity. So it's the victory of a hugely disciplined Navy, of gun crews who have been trained and trained, and all of of that takes money and it's a victory of bureaucracy. It's the victory of pit and finance and taxation
那是你自己的词吗，汤姆？那是我的词。
and a system of government borrowing and all of those things. It's the victory of an increasingly industrialized and financialized society. And yet, as you said, and I think you're absolutely right, it's also a um a story that belongs with the kind of homeric legends because of nelson dying and the moment of victory and this figure who had always seen himself as you said as the kind of what did you call him the christian achilles the christian achilles yes is that your own phrase tom that's my own phrase
是的，非常好，我自己……是的，我喜欢这个。我想，特拉法尔加确实奠定了19th世纪英国帝国主义的基础。显然，我对这个故事的态度比我10岁时阅读特拉法尔加海战时要更加微妙，对吧？更加复杂，也许也更加矛盾。但我仍然无法抑制自己对特拉法尔加所展现出的勇气中的戏剧性和史诗般品质的激动之情。这就是我所指的史诗感，就像我对阿基里斯的感觉一样，尽管他杀死了很多人。
yes very nice myself yeah i like that i think i mean like that. I think that Trafalgar really is the making of British imperialism in the 19th century. And obviously, the attitudes I would have to that story are more nuanced than when I read about the Battle of Trafalgar when I was 10. Right. And more complicated and more ambivalent perhaps. But I still cannot help but thrill at the drama and the epic quality of the courage on display at Trafalgar. And that's how I mean it being epic, rather in the way that I do to Achilles, even though he's killing lots of people.
我确实发现那种英雄主义的品质令人激动。奇怪的是，英国国内对纳尔逊所代表的那种残酷性的反感，并非纯粹的21st世纪现象。它在摄政时期伦敦的激进反文化中就已经存在了。威廉·布莱克（William Blake）就是他们明显的代言人。他在1809年画了一幅画，他将其描述为“纳尔逊引导利维坦，其盘绕的身躯包裹着大地的国家”。这可以说是对特拉法尔加海战的一种非常“21st世纪”的回应。
There is a kind of the quality of heroism I do find stirring. And oddly, there are people in Britain who, the sense of kind of revulsion at perhaps the ferocity of what Nelson represents isn't a purely 21st century phenomenon. It is there in the radical counterculture in Regency London. So William Blake would be an obvious spokesman for them. He did a painting in 1809, which he described as Nelson guiding Leviathan in whose wreathings are enfolded the nations of the earth. So that's a kind of very 21st century response to what Trafalgar is about.
但我支持华兹华斯（Wordsworth），他在特拉法尔加战役之前——但我认为他心里想着纳尔逊，他可能心里想着尼罗河战役。在一首名为《家在格拉斯米尔》（Home at Grasmere）的诗中，他写道：“此时此刻，我无法阅读一个关于两艘勇敢的战舰在生死搏杀中交战至死的故事，而内心不感到比一个明智的人所应感到的更多的喜悦。我渴望，我燃烧，我挣扎，我的灵魂此刻就在那里。”当然，没有什么能让我想要身处特拉法尔加战役现场，但我读到它时，我确实能感受到其中的戏剧性和力量。哦，是的，
But I'm with Wordsworth, who before Trafalgar, but I think he's got Nelson in his mind. He's probably got the Battle of the Nile in his mind. In a poem called Home at Grasmere, he wrote, I cannot at this moment read a tale of two brave vessels matched in deadly fight and fighting to the death but i am pleased more than a wise man ought to be i wish i burn i struggle and in soul i'm there now i would nothing would make me want to be at the battle of trafalgar but i do read it and I feel a sense of the drama and the power of it oh yeah
绝对是的。我记得我多次提到约翰·萨格登（John Sugden）的出色传记，我在报纸上为之撰写书评时的最后一行写道：这是对他成就的致敬：当纳尔逊倒在甲板下奄奄一息、鲜血涌入胸膛、军官们强忍着泪水、哈迪紧紧握着他的手时，你会祈祷某种奇迹发生——超越所有的理智和常理——让英国最伟大的英雄能够挺过去。我想你在阅读海战记录时确实会有这种感觉。即使是现在，我也有这种感觉：这是一个了不起的故事。他是一个绝对非凡的人物，
absolutely I remember I mentioned a few times John Sugden's brilliant biography and the last line that I wrote when I reviewed that for the newspapers I said it was a tribute to his achievement that as Nelson lies stricken below decks gasping for air blood pouring into his chest his officers biting back the tears and hard wringing his hand. You pray that somehow, against all sense and reason, England's greatest hero might just pull through. And I think you do feel that reading the accounts of the back. I felt that even now, that there's this tremendous story. He's an absolutely extraordinary character,
那种个人魅力，对部下的关怀，冲劲，活力，自信……而且它确实——请允许我使用“好莱坞”这个词——它确实有一种好莱坞式的结局，在胜利的时刻死去。我的意思是，他与博·布鲁梅尔（Beau Brummell）和拜伦（Byron）并列，堪称某种雏形时期的电影明星。我的意思是，他不仅是个多面手，还是一个媒体名流。但我的意思是，他的意义远不止于此。安德鲁·兰伯特（Andrew Lambert）撰写了另一部关于纳尔逊的传记，他的总结是：
that charisma, the concern for his men, the dash, the vigour vigor the self-belief um and it and it does feel i may use the word hollywood i mean it does feel like a hollywood ending dying in the moment of triumph well i mean he's up there with beau brummel and byron as a kind of proto film star i mean he is that he is a a media celebrity as well as everything else but i mean he he is so much more than that. And Andrew Lambert, who wrote another biography of Nelson, his summary was,
纳尔逊凭借其卓越的战争天赋、道德和政治勇气以及做出终极牺牲的意愿，迎战并击败了对国家独立和繁荣的最大挑战。我认为，无论这种后果因矛盾心理而蒙上多少阴影——我不矛盾……不矛盾，是的，在某种程度上，在某种程度上，是的。这就是……多米尼克，你正在做这件事，你在做你的儿童读物系列，
Nelson met and defeated the greatest challenge to the independence and prosperity of his country through his genius for war, moral and political courage and willingness to make the ultimate sacrifice. And I think it's worth paying tribute to those qualities no matter how shaded by ambivalence the i'm not ambivalent consequences i'm not ambivalent yeah to a degree to a degree yeah this is this is the difference between chipping well dominic you you are doing it you're doing your children's your series of children's books
对吧？正当其时，是的……这是一个向年轻一代的爱国者讲述纳尔逊故事的绝佳机会。你打算写谁？好吧，我打算写……好吧，你要写拿破仑？我打算写……你为什么这么恨英国？但纳尔逊会出现在书里，汤姆。拿破仑是反派。拿破仑是反派，而纳尔逊……拜托，我觉得你应该撕掉计划，直接写纳尔逊。汉密尔顿夫人的戏份太多了，我要说的是，
aren't you yeah just in time yeah um and uh perfect opportunity to tell the story of nelson for a young generation of patriots and who are you doing it on well i'm going to okay fine you're going to do napoleon i'm going to do why do you hate why do you hate britain but nelson will be in it tom napoleon is the villain napoleon is the villain on nelson come on i think you should rip your plans up and do it on Nelson There's too much Lady Hamilton I would say
我不认为年轻读者会对那种枝节有太多耐心，他们会说——他们会喜欢的。他们不会想要更多打斗。总之，听着，
I don't think the young readers will have much tolerance for that kind of carry on They'll just say They'll love it They won't want more fighting Anyway listen
这是一个极其可悲的结局。为了国家利益，我呼吁你：汤姆，你漏掉了一个绝招。难道你现在不应该说“英国期望”吗？我期望。
this is an incredibly pathetic ending I'm calling on you for the good of the nation. Tom, you've missed a trick. Surely what you should be saying is England expects. I expect.
是的。我期望。所以，霍雷肖·纳尔逊，我想我们可以安全地说他是“历史的剩余”的老朋友了。非常亲密的朋友。嗯，我想，我们以后还会再谈到他，因为我们已经审视了他如何死去，
Yes. I expect. So Horatio Nelson, I think we can safely say a friend of the rest is history. A very close. Well, I think, and I think we'll come back to him because we've looked at how he died.
我们审视了他生命的最后一年，但我认为他整个职业生涯的轨迹都如此戏剧化和非凡。鉴于汤姆设法整理了关于特拉法尔加战役的7000页笔记，我简直不敢想象他会对纳尔逊写出什么来。所以听着，非常感谢大家一直陪伴我们走到这里。汤姆，请允许我直言，这是一场杰作。你坚持对特拉法尔加战役进行多期节目的愿望已经得到了圆满的证明。所以希望你……希望你感到满意。好吧，我想
We've looked at the last year of his life, but I think that the entire course of his career is so dramatic and extraordinary. And given that Tom managed to compile 7,000 pages of notes on the Battle of Trafalgar, I dread to think what he'll come up with for Nelson. So listen, thank you very much for sticking with us through all this. Tom, dare I say, it has been a tour de force. And your desire to do multiple episodes on the battle of trafalgar has been triumphantly vindicated so i hope you're i hope you're satisfied well what i would like to
说的是，那些作为“历史的剩余”俱乐部成员的听众们，祝你们特拉法尔加日快乐！那些还不是会员的听众们……希望你们周五过了一个愉快的特拉法尔加日。我为光荣的记忆举杯。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的剩余》。如需收听独家节目、提前收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社群，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。
say is that uh those of you who are members of the rest history club a very very happy trafalgar day um those of you who aren't um i hope you had a good trafalgar day on Friday. And I raise a toast to the glorious memory. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com.
我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的剩余》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和八卦的来源。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想享受无广告收听、独家节目和提前收听权限，本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《The Rest Is Entertainment》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一点点娱乐圈八卦的固定栏目。在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想享受无广告收听、额外单集和提前收听福利的话。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。